this is my thing guys we cannot just
keep coming to the aid of women because
they cry and whine this is what has
gotten us into trouble in the first
place us voted like this is what happens
women cry and we whine and we know we
have this like power over men um you
know this is clearly conscious I don't
think every time women do it it's a
conscious thing but it it's it's like
the these events keep popping up where
women literally make up like you
can't even say this wasn't intentional
planned um I mean it probably obviously
poorly planned like at least get knacked
or to hit you or something you know what
I mean like commit if you're going to
commit commit you know